excellent see what is the main aim of
this task force we'd like to take stock
of where we are in Iraq at the moment
with stabilization efforts considering
the progress that the international ante
desh coalition has made and we would
like to stabilize wherever possible
stabilizing meaning that we would like
to make a peace dividend visible where
Josh is gone we would come in the
international community especially of
course the Iraqi authorities with ree
fixing public service with providing
local policing with providing
responsible governance etc and we have
two governor's from provinces here in at
our meeting and we have representative
from the prime minister here and that is
the aim and we're think I think we're
making progress in the focus of the of
today's meeting was the province of
unbar what can you tell me about the
current situation there well as you know
the government is planning to make
further advances with regard to Fallujah
but we've also discussed the situation
where it is very laudable that the road
between Baghdad and I'm on between Iraq
and Jordan is reopened because of the
military successes and it's important to
to really support that now with
stabilization efforts with fighting
still ongoing in part of the province
how is it possible to work on
stabilization on infrastructure projects
how's this possible well it's absolutely
important to make progress with regard
to the anti explosive devices works with
regard to demining because in cities
like Ramadi and in others this is the
main obstacle for moving in and fixing
the public infrastructure thank you very
much